>>> THE HIGH STAKES MIDTERM
SEASON IS KICKING INTO FULL GEAR
BUT THIS TIME IT'S NOT JUST
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE A SENATE
ON THE LINE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID IN PHILADELPHIA
THURSDAY, THE CHOICE ON THE
BALLOT WILL HELP DETERMINE THE
FATE OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> DONALD TRUMP AND THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS REPRESENT AN
EXTREMISM THAT THREATENS THE
VERY FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
REPUBLIC.
MAGA REPUBLICANS DO NOT RESPECT
THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
THEY DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF A FREE ELECTION.
>> AND LAST NIGHT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDED,
SAYING THIS ABOUT THE MAN WHO
DEFEATED HIM IN 2020.
>> HE'S AN ENEMY OF THE STATE,
YOU WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
THE ENEMY OF THE STATE IS HIM
AND THE GROUP THAT CONTROL HIM,
WHICH IS CIRCLING AROUND HIM, DO
THIS, DO THAT, JOE.
YOU HAVE TO DO THIS, JOE, RIGHT?
>> JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS CNN'S SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST AND SENIOR EDITOR FOR
THE ATLANTIC RON BROWNSTEIN AND
BARBARA WALTER PROFESSOR OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO AND ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK "HOW CIVIL WARS START AND
HOW TO STOP THEM."
RON, I DO THINK WE HAVE TO HIT
THE PAUSE BUTTON AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT TRUMP SAID LAST NIGHT.
THOSE REMARKS CALLING -- HERE
YOU HAVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES CALLING THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AN ENEMY OF THE STATE.
DID DONALD TRUMP JUST PROVE JOE
BIDEN'S POINT?
>> LOOK, I THINK THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS THE LEADER OF AN
UN-DEMOCRATIC FACTION IN
AMERICAN POLITICS THAT IS NOW
THE DOMINANT FACTION IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S NOT THE ENTIRE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
VERY CLEAR AND EXPLICIT IN
MAKING THAT CASE DURING, YOU
KNOW, DURING HIS SPEECH LAST
WEEK.
BUT IT IS THE DOMINANT FACTION
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE RESULTS OF
THE PRIMARIES THIS SUMMER TRUMP
STYLE ELECTION DENIERS ARE
WINNING IN STATE AFTER STATE.
WHAT I HAVE FOUND TO BE
EXTREMELY REVEALING IS THE
REACTION FROM SO MANY OTHER
REPUBLICAN ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
CONSERVATIVE PUNDITS TO THE
SPEECH.
AS YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ALL SAYING
IN EFFECT THAT BIDEN SMEARED ALL
OF YOU.
HE SAID ANYBODY WOULD DOESN'T
SUPPORT DEMOCRATS IS A THREAT TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
IN FACT, HE SAID THE OPPOSITE.
I THINK THE REASON WHY THEY WANT
TO PUT THAT MESSAGE OUT IS THEY
DON'T WANT THE ONE-FIFTH TO
ONE-QUARTER OF REPUBLICANS THAT
POLLS CONSISTENTLY TELL US ARE
UNEASY WITH TRUMP AND TRUMPISM
TO BELIEVE THEY HAVE ANOTHER
CHOICE BUT FALLING IN LINE IN A
PARTY WHERE THEY ARE NOW CLEARLY
THE MINORITY.
>> BARBARA, YOU STUDY CIVIL
WARS.
IS PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT ABOUT
THE THREAT THE COUNTRY FACES
RIGHT NOW?
>> HE IS PARTLY THOUGH I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE WE ARE NOT ON THE
PRECIPICE OF CIVIL WAR.
BUT WE KNOW FROM JUST DECADES OF
RESEARCH ON CIVIL WARS THAT
PARCEL DEMOCRACIES -- SO WEAK
AND DECLINING DEMOCRACIES AND
THOSE DEMOCRACIES WITH POLITICAL
PARTIES THAT HAVE BROKEN DOWN
ALONG RACIAL AND RELIGIOUS LINES
ARE AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND CIVIL
WAR.
AND WE HAVE, AGAIN, AS WE JUST
HEARD, WE HAVE A BIG FACTION OF
ONE OF OUR TWO MAJOR PARTIES WHO
WANTS TO UNRAVEL OUR DEMOCRACY
BECAUSE IT NO LONGER SERVES
THEM.
THEY CAN'T WIN IF WE REMAIN A
ONE PERSON, ONE VOTE DEMOCRACY.
AND SO THAT IS THE DIRECTION
THEY'D WANT TO MOVE US INTO,
WHICH IS THAT DANGEROUS ZONE.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE DO HAVE
POLITICAL PARTIES THAT HAVE
DEFINITELY BROKEN DOWN ALONG
RACIAL AND RELIGIOUS LINES.
SO AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THESE TWO FEATURES IN OUR
COUNTRY, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE AT INCREASING RISK OF
VIOLENCE IN THE FUTURE.
>> AND, RON, I WANT TO PLAY
ANOTHER MOMENT FROM TRUMP'S
SPEECH LAST NIGHT WHEN HE WENT
AFTER THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO, AGAIN, ANOTHER
INCENDIARY, DANGEROUS,
IRRESPONSIBLE COMMENT FROM
TRUMP.
HERE IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BECOME VICIOUS
MONSTERS, CONTROLLED BY RADICAL
LEFT SCOUNDRELS, LAWYERS, AND
THE MEDIA WHO TELL THEM WHAT TO
DO, YOU PEOPLE RIGHT THERE, AND
WHEN TO DO IT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SILENCE ME
AND, MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY ARE
TRYING TO SILENCE YOU, BUT WE
WILL NOT BE SILENCED.
RIGHT?
>> NOW, IN RESPONSE TO THAT,
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY TWEETED
THIS.
TRUMP IS ATTACKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND YET AGAIN USING
LANGUAGE HE KNOWS WILL PROVOKE
VIOLENCE.
ONLY ONE GROUP OF AMERICANS HAS
A CHANCE TO DIMINISH THIS
DANGER -- REPUBLICANS.
IF MY FELLOW REPUBLICANS FAIL TO
STEP UP TO STOP THIS, THEY WILL
SHARE THE BLAME FOR ALL THAT
FOLLOWS.
RON, I MEAN, YOU KNOW, BARBARA
IS RIGHT IN THAT WE'RE NOT ON
THE EDGE OF FALLING INTO A CIVIL
WAR GOING INTO A CIVIL WAR WHERE
PEOPLE ARE KILLING EACH OTHER IN
THE STREETS.
BUT THIS KIND OF LANGUAGE CAN
INCITE VIOLENCE AND ISN'T THAT
THE POINT HERE?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I'VE WRITTEN I
BELIEVE WE ARE IN THE MODERN
EQUIVALENT OF THE 1850s AND WE
ARE FUNCTIONALLY ALREADY IN A
COLD WAR BETWEEN TWO FACTIONS
WITH FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
VISIONS FOR WHAT THE COUNTRY
SHOULD BE.
LIZ CHENEY IS RIGHT
FUNDAMENTALLY.
PEOPLE WHO STUDY THIS
INTERNATIONALLY WILL SAY THAT
THE KEY, I WILL DEFER TO
PROFESSOR WALTER ON THIS, BUT
WHEN DEMOCRACIES ARE THREATENED
BY UN-DEMOCRATIC FORCES THE KEY
IS WHAT DOES THE CENTER RIGHT
DO?
DO THEY TRY TO ISOLATE THOSE
UN-DEMOCRATIC FORCES OR DO THEY
TRY TO BENEFIT FROM THEM, FROM
THEIR ENERGY IN THE BELIEF OFTEN
MISTAKEN THAT THEY CAN CONTROL
IT AND HARNESS IT.
CERTAINLY REPUBLICANS THROUGHOUT
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND AS WE
ARE SEEING AGAIN AFTER HIS
PRESIDENCY, WITH THE REACTION TO
THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH WARRANT,
THEY HAVE CHOSEN THE FORMER
STRATEGY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET THE
BENEFITS OF HOW TRUMP ENERGIZES
HIS MOVEMENT WITHOUT CONFRONTING
THE FULL SCALE REALITY OF THE
LEVEL OF THREAT THAT HE POSES TO
DEMOCRACY AS WE HAVE KNOWN IT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE PARADOX, JIM, IS THAT WHILE
THERE ARE UNDENIABLE ELECTORAL
BENEFITS TO THE ENERGY TRUMP HAS
UNLEASHED THERE IS ALSO A REAL
COST.
THERE IS THE POTENTIAL THAT A
NORMAL MIDTERM ELECTION WHICH
WOULD HAVE BEEN A REFERENDUM ON
THE PARTY IN POWER THAT PROBABLY
WOULD NOT HAVE GONE VERY WELL
FOR DEMOCRATS IS CLEARLY
EVOLVING INTO SOMETHING MUCH
MORE OF A CHOICE WHERE THEY HAVE
MUCH MORE OF A FIGHTING CHANCE
AND PART OF THAT IS THE SUPREME
COURT ON ABORTION BUT PART OF IT
ALSO IS VOTERS ASKING ARE THEY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
RE-EMERGENCE OF TRUMP TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE SEEN.
>> REPUBLICANS WANT THE MIDTERMS
TO BE ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND DONALD
TRUMP IS MAKING IT ABOUT HIMSELF
RIGHT NOW.
BARBARA, YOU WRITE NOT ONLY
ABOUT CIVIL WARS BUT HOW TO
PREVENT THEM, RIGHT IN THE TITLE
OF YOUR BOOK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS?
IS IT HELPFUL IN TERMS OF EASING
THE DIVIDE FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO CALL OUT THE THREAT?
IS IT HELPFUL IN PREVENTING
DAMAGE DONE TO OUR DEMOCRACY BY
CALLING IT OUT AND HAVING A
DISCUSSION LIKE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
PLAYING WHAT TRUMP WAS SAYING
LAST NIGHT AND HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION?
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT IS A REALLY FINE LINE
WHERE YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
UNUSUALLY OR UNREASONABLY
ALARMIST.
YOU DON'T WANT TO CREATE A SENSE
OF FEAR IN THE POPULATION SO
THAT THEY BECOME UNEASY AND THEY
FEEL THREATENED.
THAT IS IN FACT WHAT DONALD
TRUMP IS TRYING TO DO.
HE IS ENGAGING IN FEAR MONGERING
AS A WAY TO GAIN SUPPORT, WHICH
IS A VERY DANGEROUS STRATEGY IN
THE LONG TERM.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL AND I THINK BIDEN HAS
BEEN QUITE CAREFUL.
IT IS TWO YEARS INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY.
WE KNOW THAT AMERICA'S DEMOCRACY
HAS BEEN DECLINING SINCE 2016.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE'S
REALLY COME OUT PUBLICLY AND
STATED IT VERY CLEARLY.
AND THE REASON HE'S DOING THAT
IS HE DOESN'T WANT PEOPLE TO
BECOME AFRAID.
BUT THE REALITY IS IF YOU DON'T
SAY ANYTHING, IF YOU STICK YOUR
HEAD IN THE GROUND, THIS
ACTUALLY ALLOWS -- MAKES IT
EASIER FOR THOSE WHO DO WANT TO
CREATE SOME SORT OF
AUTHORITARIAN OR STRONG MAN
MINORITY RULED GOVERNMENT HERE,
SORT OF SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU HAVE
IN HUNGARY, IT ALLOWS THEM TO DO
THAT MORE EASILY.
THEY CAN DO IT QUIETLY BEHIND
THE SCENES.
AND NO ONE IS LOOKING.
AND WHAT BIDEN DID WAS REALLY HE
LIFTED THE CURTAIN ON THAT.